welcome back to the studio yesterday a
difficult game against alia what
happened there um i was like
completely winning the entire game and
then
i decided to like
not win
did you spot
after the game this move rook to d7 did
anybody show it to you yeah i was okay
like i s i checked it myself and i saw
it and then my mom texted me saying she
saw it now she's like really annoyed
already
but yeah well today you uh came guns
blazing with the black pieces did you
expect this uh choice of opening by
white
um
i mean like kinda was one of the lines i
expected
um i thought she would go like e3 first
and said bishop takes f6 but i looked at
this too
and one thing that we had actually
problems with we thought white is doing
perfectly fine and then we looked at the
engine and the engine was saying no no
no black is more or less okay maybe even
better did you feel that way i felt like
i was doing better like after b5 i was
like her bishop is pretty immobile and
like i thought this would
be like a lot easier for me to play than
her
like e4 and g4 pretty weak i just i
didn't know what
she could do other than like throw her
pieces at the king side but i felt like
i was pretty well defended anyways well
definitely assessed it better than all
the gm's on the panel hey speak for
yourself
[Applause]
see what we have to deal with rochelle
it's a it's a rough crowd
let's keep going and uh when did you
feel like you're taking over the
initiative rochelle i mean i already
felt like i had the initiative here like
um i thought that e3 was really weak um
i played bishop d7
pretty quickly because i just thought i
could like double on the
e file and i had threats of like rook
takes e3 and bishop takes f4 and i
thought it was just like are like really
easy for me to play here
let's keep going and
just uh
one thing rochelle one of the nice ways
of doubling rook sometimes you can play
a5
a7 to e7 too not just moving the bishop
but okay
uh yeah no we liked your position too
what you did was very very good
and this was the critical moment after
g5 yeah so i was like what did you
calculate here
uh after she played c3 i regretted
playing a5 like immediately because i
was cons i was gonna go g5 here
um instead of a5 yeah i was kind of like
i was scared of like bishop takes f5 i
think
uh
and i was looking at like
g takes f4 immediately
um g takes and then i was thinking i was
like wondering if bishop takes f4 here
works
uh
so like e takes
bishop takes
f5 or no rook takes e1 sorry
um bishop takes f5 but then i can take
only eight right
with the chat wait what did i even look
at
i could have okay i
um
[Music]
so maybe you can start with bishop takes
f5 first
yeah i was looking at stuff here
i was kind of scared of
um just like
instead i could have um
instead of taking on f4 i could have
just like taken on f5 i guess i was kind
of a little bit worried after queen
takes
i think just take one f
yeah
i was definitely like pretty worried
here um that's why i didn't go for it
originally i was like i thought i was
just gonna slowly play it out with like
a5 i was expecting knight c5
which i was going to play like bishop c8
and then i have like
i could either go like knight d7 or
bishop takes c5 and and then knight d7
because b2 is also hanging
um
i thought this was
just like i thought i was going to win
this position definitely looks good for
black right it doesn't seem like white
without the g-file open has any
any initiative
so let's go back uh he she played this
move c3 and you followed it up with g5
yeah
now she took this passive route with
knight g2 after which it just feels like
you're yeah i was really surprised you
played that actually knight h5 felt like
the only way she could continue knight
takes h5 knight xh5 takes g3
yes and i think at this point rook to e2
i mean yeah i guess i thought i always
had like if i needed to i could play um
f4
or like maybe rook takes e3 at some
point
right and i think this was the critical
line rook takes c3 rook takes c3 bishop
f4 and now bishop takes f5
oh wait what i did not see that um
and this allows white to come back into
the game it seems like
yeah i literally did not see this at all
i did not consider bishop takes f5
um
but she played this move knight to g2
which uh yeah i was really surprised she
played that actually pretty much i
believe though open the gates for your
attack
to flourish and uh
yeah beautiful victory
thank you rochelle congratulations
you're going into the rest day on high
note what are you going to do during the
rest day
i don't know probably like sleep
[Laughter]